I broke the law I'm a criminal at any
moment now the LAPD could knock down my
studio door and drag me away
gavin newsom the state secret police
could pull me away because I violated
his Beach lockdown word and I did it
gleefully I first went to Huntington
Beach which is one of the OC beaches
then when we couldn't get on the beach
there I went down to Newport Beach now
you got to remember gavin newsom he
ordered his lockdown of california then
he said he was gonna start opening up
california and then he very specifically
said that he was going to shut down
beaches in Orange County Orange County
one of the few somewhat conservative
counties in a metro area of California
so we first go to Huntington Beach there
was a big protest of this lockdown
on Friday so we thought we'd get on the
beach they have not only the yellow tape
up at all the beach entrances they have
cops patrolling that yellow tape so even
if you wanted to break the rules and go
onto the beach the cops would just grab
you right as you tried to walk on not
just that there were helicopters
patrolling the beach ordering people to
go inside I took this video of one just
on my iPhone
[Music]
[Music]
this is something that was
extraordinarily eerie about not only
what we heard out of that helicopter but
even what we heard from some of the cops
walking around and from some of the
other bull horns is all of these law
enforcement officers tried to sound so
pleasant oh excuse me sorry sorry for
the inconvenience go home right now
because the state has ordered law
enforcement officers with guns to kick
you off of the beach but Ray we're
really sorry it's for your own benefit
you know so smiley so kind so nice but
the end result is the same the governor
is ordering you imprisoned in your own
homes and if you even try to go out and
take a walk in the sunshine will bully
you out of there and put you back
indoors that was Huntington you couldn't
get on the beach in Huntington was
impossible so we drove about 10 minutes
down the road down PCH and got to
Newport Beach Newport Beach a little
more a freedom-loving down there there
were people on the beach so we walked
onto the beach and then at a certain
point the lifeguard SUVs rolled up
followed by the cop SUVs rolling up with
the same message ordering people off the
beach now what's so interesting about
this video again I just got it on my
phone is the lifeguards and the cops
they order everyone off the beach and
the people on Newport Beach that they
just don't move
alright it goes on there's still some
more you know please leave the beach hey
everybody the governor leaves the bee
and as they're driving by there's just
people sitting there in their chair is
like oh hey officer are you doing
bye-bye
that's the the better attitude toward it
I think Newport was a lot better than
than Huntington in terms of the people
who were going to the beach the cops
patrolled no one really paid attention
some people maybe left a little bit then
the minute the cops are gone the people
just went right on the beach and that
was that the beach closures have nothing
to do with public health this is the key
takeaway that I saw firsthand the beach
closures are purely punitive they are
just meant to punish you they're just
meant to make you feel bad now how do we
know this well for starters there's a
research that just came out of the Queen
Elizabeth Hospital Foundation Trust in
the University of East Anglia in England
which shows that a deficiency of vitamin
D apparently makes the corona virus far
more dangerous compared the average
vitamin D levels of 20 European
countries with kovat 19 mortality rates
found significant relationships between
vitamin D and the number of deaths
caused by this infection so it basically
stands to reason if you go out and get a
little bit of sunshine you're gonna be
healthier than if you stay cramped in
this these dank indoor spaces all the
time obviously if we want to keep our
vitamin D levels up no better place to
do in Southern California than at the
beach they don't care they're ordering
you indoors another reason this is
ridiculous the beaches are huge so one
thing I saw in Huntington Beach is the
huge wide Beach is totally empty the
sidewalks packed full of people if you
want people to social distance how about
you open up the giant open spaces if you
did that people obviously would be far
further apart than they would be
otherwise when I I finally did make it
down to Newport Beach once the cops went
away I just went down with my chairs
hung out there for a few hours we
weren't just six feet apart we were
probably 30 or 40 feet apart at that
point but it doesn't matter Gavin
Newsome but that's not the point the
point is not to social distance third
reason why fresh air is always good
having a little fresh air is good for
the body especially when we're talking
about air borne illnesses I
you can be cramped up cooped up with
people and sharing the same stagnant air
or you can be out in the fresh air but
the the key giveaway that this is just
political punishment is that Newsom
singled out his political opponents
County OSI the volume of density the
volume of people and concentrated space
particularly in a few cities few coastal
cities off and around the Orange County
area
those were the point of particular
concern so today we want to make some
clarifications we're gonna do a hard
close in that part of the state just in
the Orange County area yeah just in that
area Orange County area you know just in
that area that voted against me when I
ran for governor just just in that area
you jerks you monsters yeah the other
areas there okay but just in that one
area full of my political opponents
pathetic stuff what did I do at the
beach what did I do
when I was violating the law I ate a
taco and I read the Aeneid and I caught
some sunshine that's it
that's but that's pretty much all
anybody was doing reading a book kind of
listening to music drinking a little bit
that's it okay everyone was very far
apart all that this is about is just
politicians covering their derrieres it
occurred to me while sitting on the
beach this is gonna get a lot worse
before it gets any better not because of
the virus but because of the politics of
it why there's increasing evidence that
the lockdowns didn't save a single life
not just that they were ineffective but
that they didn't save a single life the
two the only two things the lockdowns
can accomplish are flatten the curve so
as not to overwhelm the hospital system
and flatten the curve until we can get a
point but we can get to a point where we
have a vaccine and that will save a lot
of lives
however we didn't come close to
overwhelming the hospital system even in
the places that were at the center of
the epidemic
so that that argument off the table
we're not close to a vaccine and there's
increasing evidence that the virus is
spreading much
faster there were many many more people
infected than we thought that there were
and so it it seems very unlikely if not
impossible that we're gonna get a
vaccine before this virus spreads
throughout a huge portion of the
population so there's no evidence that
the lockdowns accomplished much of
anything at all there is increasing
evidence that the governors and the
mayors need to convince people that the
lockdowns were necessary you're even
seeing this at the federal government
federal state and local and so we need
to have these politicians think we need
to have these punitive measures like
beach closures to play on cognitive
dissonance that's that's the principle
that's a play here what is cognitive
dissonance so when you're seeing a
disagreement between your behavior and
what you see intellectually to be true
there's more to it than that but that's
a simple description of it what people
are seeing what people are reasoning
through intellectually is the lockdowns
were an overreach they increasingly do
not seem to be necessary they
increasingly seem to be making things
worse right because the economy has
completely crashed people's livelihoods
are being ruined suicide rates are gonna
go up drug drug overdose rates are gonna
go up people are looking at and saying
well this is a bad policy and even if it
made sense five weeks ago it certainly
doesn't make sense now right
and yet the politicians have doubled
down on it to make it seem like it was
necessary and so they're they're forcing
people back indoors they're forcing
people away from the beach they're not
letting anybody return to anything even
slightly resembling a normal life Gavin
Newsom says it's not going to just be
weeks it's gonna be months before we
reopen churches we're gonna all the
things that really matter to you we're
not going to reopen because if we're all
cooped up inside if we're not gonna walk
on the beach even though it's perfectly
fine to walk on the beach following all
the rules you can still go to the beach
if we stay cooped up inside we're gonna
feel like this is a super serious thing
our behavior is going to be telling us
that this is the end of the world and we
have to stay indoors and so it will be
easier to convince ourselves that the
politicians were right in the first
place but they're not this is a complete
political rear-end covering right now
and all of the incentives are going to
in place for politicians to make this
worse you know on a very simple shallow
level it people think that politicians
want to make this easier for us they
wanted us to help go back to work they
want us be able to go outside and enjoy
ourselves enjoy the sunshine no it
actually will be better for the alarmist
politicians if this feels tougher on us
because it makes it look like they were
right
[Music]
[Music]